has to seem a real you know like North
Korea is not as bad as I thought it was
it's kind of nice you know like making
me sound gay
[Music]
so you guys know that there's a dude who
went to North Korea because he wanted to
get arrested so he could stay there what
oh are you talking about the white
deserter during the war and then they
praised them like um
like a hero during the Korean he's white
he was a white guy that deserted that
way wow like Last Samurai the last time
right Korean man
he lived a good life he has all this
silver teeth because of the dental work
out there it's pretty wack so it's all
silver yeah he's the Silver Samurai dude
and he you know like they use them as a
propaganda tool of like dude America is
so bad that he ran to our side
he lived good and he he has a wife and
kids you think you regrets it huh you
think he regretted it I don't think so
he lived good like he came from a poor
place like in the states and then so
when he deserted and he lived like
pretty good amongst the who's who's
what the heck is that this place about
to come down someone's on top of it did
we get out of here wait there's you
people can go up there yeah
um I've never heard this ever not one
time ever how about that I thought it
was no big deal but everyone was like it
kind of made me worried because that one
sounds close to like right they're right
here right here literally right above
holy [__] it's the rebar guys man
and we make noise we're noise makers you
know what we do we make noise
1975. yeah as much as it sucks it would
be crazy to see somebody fall through
the roof right now whatever you feel
like I like how the rebokers are
explaining like what they were and like
I don't give a [__] and he was taking
forever I was like dude get out we gotta
he was such a nice guy we got 14 000
pounds of Reebok cover through here okay
we're gonna be a little noisy
so I apologize for the noise just let us
know you've got some New Jersey we tell
it how it is we make the noise when we
make the noise
um but no Joe it's not the same guy
an American man has spoken out after
purposefully getting himself arrested to
remain in North Korea Matthew Todd
Miller from Bakersfield California oh
this guy's white too of course is for
Bakersfield Travel to North Korea on
April 10 2014. wow the purpose of
getting arrested wow reports claim the
now 33 year old tore up his tourist visa
in the airport and made clear his
intentions to seek political asylum in a
bid to try and stay in the car oh so
he's doing political Asylum so he was
arrested for unruly behavior however
they arrested him anyway he said can I
have a son I'm like you're arrested yeah
North Korea couldn't look kind of tight
like hey this American Defector and like
nah you're a [__] arrested I like how
they even put him in a North Korea now
[__] McLovin he looks like Lex
Freeman in McLean the unruly Behavior
you tear up your passport and just start
yelling probably huh yeah maybe he's
just making a spectacle yeah well here's
the thing it evolved a little bit
because at first he was arrested for
unruly Behavior but the accusations
um started to get a little bit crazier
he was later accused of hostile acts
against the state after being found in
possession of a notebook he sought to
deliver to North Korea's government
which state-run Korea Central news
agency alleged contained confessions
he reportedly said he was a hacker and
new military Secrets hoping to remove
the American Military in South Korea so
he's trying to be a double agent spy or
some [__] I guess so the Supreme Court
of the Democratic Republic uh People's
Republic of Korea ruled Miller had
committed acts of hostile to the dprk
while entering the territory of dprk
under the guise of a tourist the
Californian man was charged after under
article 64 of the North Korean criminal
code concerning the acts of Espionage
and certainly achieved his goal of
remaining North Korea as he was
sentenced to six years of hard labor and
see I would have done the same [__] but
he played the wrong cards what I would
have done is I would have been like Kim
Jong-il sister I'm here to love you
that's good you know what I mean like I
would have been like yo I [__] left
America to be with you you're my true
love he has a blue box you start air
humping yeah this is what I could do for
you that'd be good that's very alluring
I'd be like yeah everybody American dick
before yeah and I'm like check this out
and he's like I want to be the king of
North Korea and you'll be my queen yeah
that's really good yeah
yeah yeah and then she'd just be like oh
my God foreign
yeah I'm like Genghis Khan but like the
Communist version right but then no we
could
co-operate with Kim Jong-un and we can
be like a throuple that's really good
you want to throttle with Kim Jong oh
wow I picture Joe getting there and then
he's like
all right so what do we get to eat
around here
what happens at the end of the six years
hard labor do they let him out into
actual North Korea or they just send
them back I don't know but considering
his situation Miller also spent nearly
six months in custody prior to his
conviction having refused to be flown
back to the U.S and resultantly being
detained nobody wanted it to stay there
no he wants to stay there yeah but even
though he was like get the [__] do you
think his military secrets are from
Starcraft too yeah like I know how to
move troops and how to accumulate wealth
you know what he said he said quote this
might sound strange but I was prepared
for the torture but instead of that I
was killed with kindness and with that
my mind folded and the plan fell apart
so what was his plan this guy's weird
dude he's just mental telling him
everybody was so nice to me yeah his
intention apparently he said that he
wanted to see North Korea in a way which
went beyond the average tourist
experience of it I just wanted to have a
face-to-face face with North Koreans to
answer my personal questions and then
they sent them back to the US they're
like we don't want this one they're like
you're just crazy dude they're like
we're gonna do a bunch of trumped up
charges on you and put you into a
military Camp wait he said he wanted
North Korea he was met with kindness he
wanted North Koreans to answer his
questions he just wanted to like see it
in a different way than regular people
he said I achieved my personal goal of
seeing more of North Korea I wanted to
connect with the people not question the
government or the politics I have no
personal politics this was not a
political trip yeah it's a schizophrenic
trip yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
think it's because all the all the uh
tourism there it's like State controlled
so they only expose you to what they
want you to see so everything is like a
a facade right so he probably wanted to
see the real real he's like one of those
tourists that are like I'm not going to
the resort I want to go to where the
locals go but it's like the more
hardcore version of it yeah I want to go
to the jails where everyone does the
Work Camp stuff he's a pretentious
driver and he's like
like it's not that bad this isn't the
real North Korea it's like this is like
the real [__] North Korea and
everything else is a tourist trap this
is where the [__] locals hang I know
oh excuse me it's Jung Yang Pyongyang
yeah not like Pyongyang the locals don't
even eat that yeah they don't they eat
these [__] like these little bugs
like yeah these little rats he's like
patient zero of like gentrifying an
entire country
such a California thing to do right like
I want to go to the real North Korea the
real one
I love we gave him that voice yeah he's
like he's a little sassy though
it's like he's got that he's turtleneck
this is a mom-and-pop's nation
he said uh he's neither confirm nor
denied whether or not there is any
truths to the Espionage charges simply
explaining he was not there to give
secret information or anything like that
but just wanted to speak to an ordinary
North Korean person about normal things
I just wanted to I wanted to just every
day sit down with them and have
conversations about everything in jail I
would ask them one question about their
country and they would have a question
about mine he said wait so he could
speak Korean no I think he just wanted
to the dumb thing is if he's saying if
he's releasing this information while in
captivity of North Korea then it's
clearly North Korea talking yeah Oh I
thought he was released no no he's got
six six years of hard labor yeah so why
are you why would anyone go oh really
like no you're under captivity man
yeah North Korea that's not your voice
anymore yeah you got it that's that's
the problem with like Blockbuster
shutting down that used to be like the
home for weirdos like this you know all
the weird [__] Michelle's like where
are you going with this one he would
have had a home they shut that [__] down
now he has to go [__] find the
secrets of North Korea he's like
Hollywood Videos closed all right that's
what they said when he got there oh
I mean I'm just imagining the North
Korea PR agent who's like writing this
guy's speech and he goes you know we
cannot make it seem a fake it has to
seem a real you know like North Korea is
not as bad as I thought it was it's kind
of nice you know like making me sound
gay
they will not believe
he said yeah you know California is
always a vegan and like a game Welcome
Center look again for blogger
but as I thought it was it was the
locals I like to go eat it
[Music]